on va se dire franchement la s'il y a
une mesure qu'on n'avait pas vu venir
dans ce budget là hier c'est bien les
mesures comme par exemple le droit à la
réparation on a beaucoup parlé d'énergie
vite mais ça ça rentre dans le détail
vous savez les appareils électroménagers
ou électroniques vous voulez les réparer
on va appeler quelqu'un où je vais aller
chercher la pièce ah ça se fait pas et
c'est irréparables pensez au chargeur de
téléphone ou de tablettes il y a rien
d'universel dans tout ça alors il y a
moyen de travailler là-dessus pour
réduire les déchets électroniques et
comme de coïncidence et tiennent le
blanc notre chroniqueuse spécialisé en
environnement vous liés nous parler de
ça précisément cette semaine j'ai envie
de dire qu'elle a donc comme vous le
dites-vous mais c'est plein de bon sens
d'ailleurs il y a déjà d'autres régions
dans le monde qui agissent la semaine
dernière l'Union européenne annonçait
tout un plan de match pour élaborer le
droit à la réparation c'est quoi le
droit à la réparation parce
qu'évidemment on a toujours des
appareils à faire réparer et on se dit
dans le fond on devrait avoir le droit
de les réparer tous les appareils à
l'endroit de son choix or c'est pas le
cas vous le vous le remarquez quand vous
essayez de faire réparer un appareil
prenez votre téléphone par exemple c'est
un problème de conception ça c'est un
premier frein à la réparation parce que
votre téléphone selon les marques il est
soit soudé à l'intérieur coller
impossible pour un réparateur qui n'est
pas certifié de réparer votre téléphone
évidemment le fabricant va vous charger
très très cher et vous dire faut en
acheter un nouveau ça c'est un premier
frais deuxième frais c'est que dans
certains appareils il y a des pièces qui
sont uniques des petites vis qui ne sont
qu'avec le tournevis conçu par la
compagnie en question donc R3 dans le
monde exactement donc impossible et
d'autres choses par exemple les fermiers
le vivent avec par exemple les tracteurs
John Deere John Deere qui est un très
mauvais joueur dans le droit à la
réparation parce que il empêche les
fermiers ou les garagistes qui
travaillent avec les fermiers d'avoir
accès par exemple au log essentiel dans
les tracteurs qui sont aujourd'hui
fondamentaux c'est des ordinateurs sur
Caro les tracteurs aujourd'hui donc
plusieurs fins plusieurs freins comme ça
à la réparation qui nous empêche de
faire réparer nos produits donc on en
achète des nouveaux bon avez-vous vu
quelque chose dans le budget ou est-ce
que des mesures ou qui peuvent être
améliorées donc c'est ça dans le budget
on annonce dans le fond qu'il y aura
d'ici 2024 un plan pour le droit à la
réparation donc qu'est-ce qu'il y aura
dans ça ça reste à voir il y a plusieurs
choses qui pourraient y avoir on
pourrait avoir des mesures d'éco-fis
qualité donc inciter soit les
entreprises ou donner des bonnets
fiscaux aux consommateurs qui font
l'effort de faire réparer leurs
appareils on pourrait aussi obliger les
entreprises soit concevoir des appareils
qui s'ouvrent avec des avec des vis et
des petits tournevis il y a des choses
qui se font c'est on appelle ça
l'éco-conception il y a des compagnies
comme fairphone des Pays-Bas qui font un
téléphone qui s'ouvre avec un petit
tournevis si vous pouvez le réparer
vous-même ou le faire réparer la pile
s'enlève tous les éléments s'enlèvent et
il y a certaines compagnies comme Nokia
par exemple qui offrent aujourd'hui un
téléphone réparable donc les choses
changent et l'autre chose que pourrait
faire le gouvernement ce serait de
d'obliger les compagnies à donner accès
à l'information c'est-à-dire au logiciel
dont je parlais par exemple il pourrait
le faire ça a des conséquences
environnementales très graves le fait
qu'on puisse pas réparer nos produits au
Canada on n'est pas un bon joueur chaque
Canadien produit Marc-André 20 kg de
déchets qui sont liés soit nos appareils
électroménagers où nous apparaît
électroniques 20 kg par personne par
année la moyenne mondiale c'est 7 kg et
ça a des conséquences parce que ces
produits là déversent dans
l'environnement des métaux lourds ça
prend énormément d'eau pour extraire les
minéraux critiques pour fabriquer nos
appareils électroniques et les gaz
infectés aussi vous savez dans votre
téléphone 70% des gaz à effet de serre
qui ont été utilisés pour le produire
proviennent de l'extraction des minéraux
donc ça a des conséquences
environnementales réelles c'est pour ça
que mettre des règles c'est très très
pertinent
rendez-vous l'heure on va vous donner
xnome de dollars la compagnie de faire
quelque chose avec elle doit l'ouvrir et
récupérer du matériel ça se peut
récupérer le matériel ce serait déjà bon
ou elle le met aux poubelles et l'envoi
dans un dépôt électronique en Afrique ou
en Inde bon alors puis ça me fait penser
l'épisode souvenez vous souvenez vous de
ça les cassettes betta et VHS on allait
à un format il fallait aller vers un
format qui allait gagner alors j'ai
l'impression que dépendamment des types
d'appareils les prises universelles
aussi devraient y avoir un gagnant et le
chargeur universel mais vous savez même
la conception les consommateurs
commencent à le demander que les
téléphones soient réparables donc il y
aura peut-être des changements dans la
conception des appareils éventuellement
bon on fait pas tout ça pour rien
finalement
merci beaucoup d'être une voix on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI